procès me julie j'ai toujours su que tu
étais trop bien pour moi puis ce sera le
plus beau souvenir de la vie tulle et
déjà ça fera 25 montréal et je veux dire
tout de suite c'est le réveil souligne
cinq minutes
non je déconne j'ai besoin de retrouver
mon chemin intérieur non non non non tu
as juste besoin de tout trouver un mec
je suis belle et j'ai ce petit truc en
plus tu donnes un char le foot je me
suis dit que si vous comprenez cela a
changé ma vie vous seriez pense à
rassurer ça y est on est rassuré on se
casse bienvenue aux rencontres dizaines
[ __ ] c'est bien ça non
c'est juni tu as vraiment une règle
super bourgeoise toi un mets ta gueule
invite à chanter les 80 hyper je les
remets toi aussi tu me fais penser un
peu mais bon soir louise j'en peux plus
de ces mensonges
j'en veux pas de cette vie quand vous
pas le vie à deux c'est pas mon truc
il habite tous ce soir je suis allé moi
tu me fais chier pardon et charles c'est
chez toi
on est sur une bonne idée parce que
frein pas
je sais que c'est mitigé passage
les magic
ça donne l'impression que tout est
possible
on n'y est pas on fait quoi là
maintenant on continue